EVERYONE SHOULD REJECT.
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: TRACE GALLAGHER.
THANKS A LOT FOR THAT.
TODAY'S REPORT IS DAMNING.
COULD IT HAVE BEEN WORSE
WITH THE ORIGINAL FINDING
SOFTENED UP PRIOR TO
RELEASE?
CONGRESSMAN JIM JORDAN
REPUBLICAN WHO REPRESENTS
OHIO.
HE HAS INTRODUCED A
RESOLUTION CALLING FOR THE
DOJ TO RELEASE MORE
DOCUMENTS ON THE
DECISION-MAKING AT THE FBI
IN 2015.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
CONGRESSMAN, THANKS A LOT
FOR COMING ON.
>> YOU BET.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, TUCKER.
>> Tucker: YOU SUSPECT THIS
IS NOT ALL THERE IS.
>> WE HAVE BEEN ASKING FOR
ALL KINDS OF DOCUMENTS.
>> WE HAVE CAUGHT THEM
HIDING DOCUMENTS.
HOW ABOUT THE FACT, TUCKER,
WE HAVE SEEN ALL THESE TEXT
MESSAGES, THOUSANDS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL SAID, I
FORGET, 50,000 TEXT MESSAGES
BETWEEN STRZOK AND PAGE.
THE ONE MOST TELLING WAS THE
ONE THAT SAYS WE'LL STOP
TRUMP.
WE DON'T SEE THAT ONE UNTIL
TODAY?
SO, YEAH, THEY HAVEN'T
COMPLIED WITH SUBPOENAS FROM
CHAIRMAN GOODLATTE,
SUBPOENAS FROM CHAIRMAN
FUNDS.
WE HAVE CAUGHT THEM TRYING
TO HIDE INFORMATION FROM US.
THEY KEPT THIS TEXT MESSAGE
UNTIL TODAY.
OF COURSE WE WANT THE
INFORMATION SO WE CAN DO OUR
JOB.
LAST THING I WOULD SAY IS
JUST REMEMBER IT WAS A
COUPLE DAYS AGO THAT WE
LEARNED THAT ROD ROSENSTEIN,
WHO IN ESSENCE RUNS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE RIGHT
NOW WAS THREATENING STAFF
MEMBERS ON THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE.
SO WHEN YOU PUT ALL THIS
TOGETHER, OF COURSE WE NEED
A RESOLUTION SAYING GIVE US
THE INFORMATION SO WE CAN DO
OUR JOB AND GET ANSWERS FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: SO UNIDENTIFIED
FBI LAWYER NUMBER TWO IN
THIS DOCUMENT IS QUOTED
LAMENTING THE FACT HE DIDN'T
TRY HARDER TO GETS HILLARY
CLINTON ELECTED AND BRAGGING
ABOUT HIMSELF AS A MEMBER OF
THE ANTI-TRUMP RESISTANCE
AND HE GOES TO WORK FOR
MUELLER.
WHY DON'T I AS A CITIZEN
HAVE A TRITE KNOW WHO THAT
IS AND WHAT IS HE DOING NOW.
>> I AGREE WITH YOU.
IN FACT WE TWEETED HOW THE
WHO IS LAWYER NUMBER TWO.
WE WANT TO KNOW.
LAWYER NUMBER TWO JUST LIKE
STRZOK AND JUST LIKE PAGE
WAS ON THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION.
HE WAS THE LEAD LAWYER
PRIMARY LAWYER ON THE TRUMP
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
ALL THREE OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WENT ON THE
MUELLER TEAM.
SUBSEQUENTLY KICKED OFF THE
MUELLER TEAM BECAUSE OF
ANIMUS THEY HAD AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IT'S INTERESTING.
THE THREE PEOPLE THAT COME
OVER FROM THE FBI TO
MUELLER'S TEAM ALL WERE ON
THE CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
ALL WERE ON THE RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION.
ABDOMEN ALL HATED PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THAT'S INTERESTING TO ME.
SO, YEAH, WE NEED TO FIND
OUT WHO THIS INDIVIDUAL IS
AND BRING HIM IN.
PLUS, ALSO WHAT IS
INTERESTING, WE'LL STOP
TRUMP.
REMEMBER WHEN THIS HAPPENED.
THIS IS A TEXT MESSAGE FROM
AUGUST 8TH.
SO PETER STRZOK OPENS THE
TRUMP-RUSSIA INVESTIGATION
ON JULY 31ST, 8 DAYS LATER,
WE'LL STOP TRUMP.
SIX DAYS LATER WE HAVE THE
TEXT MESSAGE.
WE HAVE AN INSURANCE POLICY
TO MAKE SURE -- IF THAT
DOESN'T SHOW WHERE THESE
GUYS WERE AT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT DOES.